Narrator: To get a shot
like this from "Shang-Chi,"
Hollywood primes cars like this one
to get crushed dramatically on camera.
Workman: Drop!
Narrator: And that work is
up to the team at JEM FX,
which sets cars up for optimal destruction
in movies like "Shang-Chi,"
"Taken 3,"
and "Ghostbusters: Afterlife."
We visited JEM to see how it designs cars
to get spectacularly destroyed on-screen
exactly as planned.
In real life, cars don't
always get destroyed
in the most cinematic ways.
Even when hit repeatedly,
a car roof won't always cave in on itself
like we're used to seeing in movies.
That's where scoring comes in --
stripping away the protective
sheet metal in a car
and gutting it of its support.
Cody: We're going to start
by cutting this pillar
from here to here to basically
weaken the structure.
So, now that we've finished our cut,
we're going to take a
pry bar and simply remove
this small chunk of the front A pillar.
Narrator: Each cut determines
where and how the car will fold.
Cody: We're going to go through
and do some weakening cuts
to help this fold a little bit easier
under a little less weight.
Narrator: They target the A,
B, and C pillars of the car.
Cody: Now, when you're doing this,
you have to ensure not to cut
the outside of the vehicle,
because then it'd be visible
and you could tell something's up with it.
So we like to try and
hide all of our stuff.
Narrator: Then they put the
whole thing back together.
Cody: So, we're going to start out
by reconnecting our wire harness.
Then we'll take our interior cover,
put it back on, replace
our weather stripping.
And now we're back to the stock interior.
It looks like a normal
car from the inside,
but it will crush.
Narrator: It took four
hours to score the car,
all so it could be destroyed in seconds
by a 3,000-pound weight.
And the areas they scored
were the ones that folded cleanly.
The team at JEM doesn't go all the way
with the scoring process for every job.
Take this bus crash in "Shang-Chi."
This shot was filmed on
location in San Francisco,
and the parked cars
getting run over are real.
JEM prepped them for destruction.
The cars were supposed to
get crushed in the bus' path,
but they also needed to be strong enough
to slow down the bus.
So JEM only scored the upper
portion of the vehicles
to collapse on impact, keeping
the lower portions strong.
When the bus would carry over
the tops of the vehicles,
if it went down too far, the
scene wouldn't look right.
So all we wanted is
just so much compression
and actually provide a flat platform
for the camera to track
down the hill with.
Narrator: They can also just focus
on a few major points of weakening,
like these hinges on car doors.
Swapping out the steel
hinges for breakaway ones
makes the doors incredibly
easy to rip off.
Cody: They're made out
of a weaker compound,
which makes them shear easier.
So that way, it'll snap
the door off nice and easy.
Narrator: Then they cut these wires
to make sure the door
has nothing to hang on to
after the bolts blow out.
These weaker materials
allow for big results.
Some forms of damage can be faked,
like for scenes where an
actor crashes into something
and the hood of their
car dramatically pops up.
The team at JEM can rig
hoods to do that on cue.
Elia: So, that hood-popping rig,
basically we took a stock Crown Vic hood,
and we went inside it. We
actually scored it to a point.
So that way, when we put a cylinder on it
and we pulled it, it just
bent just like soft metal.
Narrator: They were able to do this
over and over again on the same hood,
reusing it through the
whole night of shooting.
The shop used a similar
technique to rig this truck
in "Ghostbusters: Afterlife."
Elia: And the storyline was that the ghost
is chasing this truck, and
he's punching at the truck.
Narrator: They had to make
the doors dent practically,
as if the ghost, who
would be added with CG,
was crashing into it.
To get the effect in camera,
Elia's team replicated
the door panels of the GMC pickup
in a soft conditioned aluminum
and attached the panels to a rig
that made them buckle on cue.
So that when we pulled
it with a pneumatic ram
on the inside, it sucked it in,
and it looked like the ghost
was punching these panels.
Narrator: The work isn't
limited to the car itself.
JEM pulls all sorts of tricks on set
to make sure destruction
goes according to plan,
with ramps,
cannons,
and cables.
Elia: In our world, you
only get so many seconds
to tell the story, so they
want to make it dramatic.
Cars don't always just explode on impact.
Narrator: So JEM gives them a little help.
Elia: So what we'll do is use devices,
everything from a gas
bomb underneath a vehicle
or to a, what's called a propane popper,
and attach it to the vehicle.
We'll have it fired,
whether it's on a wire,
remote control, or an impact switch.
Or sometimes even the stunt guy
will have the button inside with him.
Narrator: To make cars go
flying at the press of a button,
the shop retrofits cars with
different types of cannons,
like on this test run, for
which the team was asked
to split a truck in half.
They built a 10-inch dual-cannon
system to pull it off
and used this system on a larger scale
for this highway chase in "Taken 3."
Elia: We had to start with
a tractor trailer coming
down the highway, having to
jackknife [with] so much impact
that it caused the sea container
to fall off the trailer,
so much speed that when
it did hit the ground,
it rolled and ran over cars.
Narrator: To execute the move,
they used two 12-inch nitrogen cannons,
which provided enough inertia
to flip the trailer's shipping container.
And for the rolling part?
Elia: We welded wheels on the end
of the square sea container,
so we could roll it down the highway.
Narrator: A carefully placed
ramp can also make cars flip
in ways they would never do on their own.
Elia: So when they come
in and they hit that ramp,
then the angle, the kicker at the end
is what will send the car spiraling
and flipping over at speed.
Narrator: Productions hide
ramps on the blind side
of cars and also use set
decoration like roadblocks.
When a destruction scene calls for a car
to follow a very specific trajectory,
the job often involves cable rigs,
which can make the cars crash or spin
in a predetermined fashion.
JEM builds cable accelerators
to pull heavy vehicles in
a desired direction fast.
And limiting or suspender cables make cars
come to a full halt within a split second,
something you can't do
with regular car brakes.
They used these cables in "Bright."
Elia: David Ayer wanted us
to have a Suburban come in,
hit this imaginary wall,
and stop on a dime.
And it was all shot very, very stylistic,
so you had a side profile,
and it picks up the crumpling of the hood.
So what we did is, we
did a pull cable forward,
but we also had a stop cable going
to the front of nose of the bumper.
We actually scored and weakened the front,
so we collapsed it back
and held the vehicle
from crossing that imaginary barrier.
Narrator: Cables also helped JEM execute
one of its most customized crash jobs
for "Velvet Buzzsaw."
The truck had to slam into
the corner of this building.
That was a real building,
so we couldn't hurt the real building.
Narrator: And the car could only get hit
in a precise area on the passenger door,
so that the audience would
believe the driver survived.
To pull it off, JEM built
a whole new set element.
The team structurally embedded a fake pole
that was strong enough to
absorb the impact of the car ...
Elia: A fake pole that's
in there hard enough
that it didn't move and give
away that it was a fake pole.
Narrator: And over the car
doors placed an outer layer
made from soft conditioned aluminum.
This would help them show
more impact with less.
For a crash that might
look random and chaotic,
JEM's team will spend hours
testing and experimenting
to make sure everything happens
exactly how they want it to.
And even if it isn't realistic,
it sure looks like it.
Everything we do defies
physics. None of it makes sense.
But we get paid to do it.